oh my gosh the new Miyazaki movie is out
we should go see it we should go see it
today what's wrong with you you like
Studio gibling yeah yeah I don't think
I've seen any of their movies but yeah
Spirited Away how's Moving Castle oh did
you see there was an accident on the it
10 this morning don't change the subject
you love foreign films you love
animation so why won't you watch studio
gibli uh it's pronounced jibli I believe
why would you even know that well I'm
aware of their status and their
significance in the history of Cinema
then watch their movies I know that
Spirited Away is like a masterpiece like
100% Masterpiece then watch it yeah it's
so interesting what is
yeah anyway